guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm / tour we'll see
you there
let's talk about where we get the this
concept of object day from that's good
yes let's talk about that because I
noticed something niet said just as the
at the beginning he said that his
partner had given your documentary to
him shoot your documentary to him and he
really enjoyed it this actually is a key
to understanding how where we can object
day from is the weird thing is we think
our desires are a room they're not
they're given to us by other people and
this is called mimetic desire there's a
guy called Randy Gerard he really does
great work on this but that what happens
is when you're going out with somebody
because obviously your documentary is
terrible and so nobody would actually
like it directly right I couldn't agree
more
exactly but if someone else likes it and
I like them I start to like it because
they like it
right this is mimetic desire mimetic
desire is this weird thing where you
start saying going out with somebody and
you start to like what they like you
start to find yourself being in the
French cinema and long walks along the
beach or whatever they're in C and then
weirdly you start to think that they're
your desires and they they're into
certain bonds and then you start to be
into those bonds and then if you break
up you start to fight over humans the
CDs I mean that's a cool irreverence
dive so as your Spotify but the
interestingly what I desire is the
desire of ones I desire so that's the
most precious material in the world
right it's not Gould it's not health the
the most precious material in the world
is the desire of the desire no the
desire of the people I desire because I
desire the desire of those I desire I
want there's our but also the second
bits of that is I desire what they
desire because I if I see that what they
desire sometimes I want to kind of take
the place of that I want I want the
attention that they are giving the other
thing you imagine when you're a kid and
you see your parents
being desired something else and you
kind of want to kind of get that desire
so it's it's interesting it's important
to learn that because what Reni Gerard
says he says the problem is this right
say right you're going out with somebody
just to use the example of sexual desire
and I think you're cool which is a hard
thing for your listeners to imagine but
I think you're kind my mom says the same
thing yeah
but then here's the crazy thing right I
maybe start to desire who you desire you
say I really fancy this person and I'm
like oh and then I go like I really kind
of fancy them as well then what happens
is we get into conflict because alou
I've kind of taken the desire on because
of you I feel it's my own and now we're
in conflict with each other and it
causes lots of problems and and then we
get into what's called scapegoating and
we have to blame somebody else in order
to kind of reconcile so where does our
desire come from here's the funny thing
is your dessert you feel it's yours
whatever you desire but actually it
might be the desire of your mother your
father your siblings your friends your
taking on all of these other people's
desires and here's then even more
complicated sometimes you don't desire
your desire sometimes you end up in a
job that you kind of hit but you kind of
choose and so you obviously choose it
freely because that's what you wanted to
do but you also hear up and then you
discover that oh my goodness I'm
fulfilling the desire of my parents or
I'm desire you know this is the weird
thing by being human is we can not
desire what we desire I guess very
complicated